welcome to the Macmillan report I
Maryland volks your host and our guest
is TAS South karoke DS an associate
research scientist at Yale School of
Public Health and an affiliated faculty
member in the Hellenic studies program
at the Macmillan Center his primary
research focus is in the area of
infectious diseases with particular
emphasis on hiv/aids and its treatment
he also has an interest in the history
of medicine social determinants of
health and the socio cultural dimensions
of the benefits of a great diet today
we'll talk with Professor karoke DS
about nutrition public health and fellow
too low in Greece welcome professor
karoke DS thanks very much for having me
a great opportunity thank ya so let's
start off with the definition of salute
to mow what exactly does that mean let
me start with the literal translation
filament two words meaning love of honor
however it's hard to define that word in
one containing with one word so I'm
going to say a lot of values that come
with it its honor pride doing what's
right I've and when somebody else is not
looking the the idea of giving yourself
and then providing for somebody without
being asked so it entails a lot of
values and as the philosopher
pre-socratic philosopher Sally said if
you're not the most for Greeks is like
breathing a Greek is not a Greek without
it so and it's something that has kept
the Greeks together in hard times and
not so hard times but it's something
that it's a secret you will the Greek
yes I actually I wasn't familiar with it
and I had a look up the words of the
phrase myself so how does that relate to
nutrition and public health well Greeks
in Greek nutrition in public health as
something that the Greeks have always
kept high in there on your priorities
and your sister by well the the idea of
a healthy nutrition paradigm has always
been there for the Greek culture so the
the concept of sharing that and
providing that and sharing generation of
the generation and sharing with
strangers it is to me resonates with
that idea of Salah team of serving
others while sharing and be proud of
what your food and it is it typed in
nutrition and in public health and I
think the Greeks have realized early on
that prosperity of a nation is not just
financial it's its health so a healthy
nation I actually like that idea that a
healthy nation is a prosperous nation
not just in the financial aspect but
also in the in the health of the
individual and society okay how has the
diet change or has it changed over time
it has changed obviously the grease like
any other place has been affected by the
globalization and the ability to source
food at any given time and wherever you
are we have supermarkets that have
replaced the local grocery stores but
the the thing that has not change is how
people eat they eat with friends and
family it's always a main part of the
day to get it around the table and sort
of go through the day how was it you
know tell me your problems and let's
chat about this and it's it's more of
the the IOA's think of the this is holy
triad in the Greek culture of food
dialogue and drink not necessarily in
that order but it's the idea that you
get together you talk about your
problems you bring people together on
the table friends and enemies alike and
then you shall have a common bond over
that food and does that stretch across
all socio-economic levels in Greece it
does obviously the latest financial
crisis that we've had has affected that
but I think it has made that that
ability to gather on the table has been
maintain to the extent that it can and
across the board you'll see I don't
think I've ever been to a restaurant or
place to get some food or a grocery
store where you don't see a lot of
people together you really see somebody
sitting on their own and sometimes you
know if I find myself sitting at a
restaurant or alone other people come
and chat with me rather I don't know so
it's that idea that you know we're all
here together to enjoy something and we
need to protect you my and is it
lunchtime or more dinner time that this
happened more dinner time even though
you know you you find people taking the
hour lunch and just going out and
sitting down and eating not that you
have to tape it out your desk for a
lunch which I like when I'm there I
guess that is nice so what are some of
the anthropological component of food
and green I mean if you think about the
i'll give you another word which I think
encapsulate the this the idea of the
human being being the center or food
being in central of the existence of a
human being grease cinder fuss means
somebody you eat with and the
translation of that word means partner
whether it's a friend or a spouse so
that shows how significant that be if
you're sharing food with somebody it
means that they're high on your on your
circle so from that you have the idea of
this food and the culture propagating
over generations and not only in
families but then in villages and in
towns and regions so if you look at
Greece it's made up of not one cuisine
it's very local to regional and people
are very proud you have villages that
make the same thing but they think
there's the best recipe and or families
and all that and that's been propagated
and I think that speaks to the the
ability of this nutrition and the food
culture to propagate over time despite
the evolution of whether its climate
whether it's other external factors that
has remained as part of this society
okay so are there some kinds of food
that are traditionally prepared at
holiday
you know cultural things that have stood
the test of time going back to how food
relates to religion Greek religion and
culture go together and when it comes to
food there's two big holidays Christmas
and Easter but Easter i think is the big
holiday the religious holiday for the
Greeks and I think if you ask any Greek
they will have a memory around the lamb
the process of preparing it and how do
you you know enjoy it and what what goes
into it and there's a memory attached to
that so that I think is one example of
something that over years and years and
years and generations have remained
there it's like a preparation whether
it's going to the village or with family
in town but it's always the same process
here after you write it seems like you
have such a difference I'm wondering how
you got interested in this because you
know you study infectious diseases
basically and it seems quite a departure
between the two so what led you to so
he's always interested in food everybody
is enjoying it and but then when you
start thinking about the Greek nutrition
and the material in general has always
been known to to effective benefit to
the health of an individual and that
would be typically olive oil well the
legumes grains the limited amount of
meat a lot of fish that wine so there's
but everything in measure everything in
not exceeding certain you know don't
overdo it so from that when I started
thinking about it about 10 12 years ago
I saw this was there's a gap the gap
between the from the academic side of
things worth a lot of research is
happening by Greeks and non-greeks alike
this country and Europe or increase that
show in academic journals and
publications that this is good and on
the other side you have the people who
are actually consuming that and the only
way that that information gets
transmitted because late public is not
going to read academic journals is if
something makes the news New York Times
CNN BBC whatever so I thought how do we
bridge that gap so I started put it
together another
real events that we had it 10 years ago
at macmillan center and that brought
together people who are doing the
research but also people are actually
executing you know the the food
preparation the chefs the people are
involved in sourcing night so out of
that came this idea that food is not
just the calories consumed and we know
that what is it it's not just the
benefit we get from in health wise but
there's a bigger context here is the the
social health that is affected by that
because there's something to be said
about sitting down with somebody
enjoying good food that's good for your
health at the same time we talk with
them you engage them whether it's your
problems you're trying to share their
problems and there's something that that
is Magic I thing that happens around yet
wine helps but even without wine there's
something that makes people bond over
food that effectiveness yes I am
wondering in this country of course fast
food plays such a huge role in how
people eat in nutrition do you find the
same thing happening in Greece there is
definitely you can see more fast food
sort of places now but the interesting
thing and I try to remember from my
early years when i was there fast before
i was defined differently fast food was
healthy fast food and not the faster
that we know in this country it's
changing a little bit but you won't find
a lot of obviously younger generations
are moving toward going towards that but
at the end of the day the majority I
think for the food you consume whether
you call it fast food grilled something
it's still better than fast food
deep-fried so there's a little bit of a
difference in how you define fast food
in this country versus and Greece but
people have maintained you'll find
open-air markets where people go and
weekends and buy their lives and their
veggies in there legumes they might have
a fast food day but again the fast food
a little bit different than right so you
mentioned the youth and Greece do you
see them keeping the traditions or
perhaps changing a bit I think it's it
goes in cycles and I would say 10 years
ago you could see
a lot more younger generation the
younger people moving towards for a bit
more globalized food consumption model
now I think and it's sort of a side
effect and it is also the financial
crisis UCL a few slowly you see young
people going towards whether it's out of
necessity obviously you know agar
intrapreneurship or growing your own
veggies at home or doing something that
without maybe that was not the main
reason you went there but it's sort of a
an indirect way of bringing back to the
old way of consuming food and sourcing
food so I don't want to say well it's a
good thing that happened but it's a good
side effect of this financial crisis and
there's a lot of cases of young people
who have been unemployed for many years
and then go and be in the agriculture
sector that Greece is known for and now
we see this this movement of bringing
young people out and we're actually
trying with the agriculture university
in Athens and to collaborate and
establish some programs with the climate
health and change and climate change and
health initiative here at the school
call yourself to do something right um
you know in this country there's a huge
movement towards you know in the
opposite of fast food which is slow food
which is eating food locally ground so
it sounds like you know that's something
that's happened to increase the other
thing though I'm curious about is
because the world is much more
globalized do you see different cultures
coming in Chinese food Italian food
wealth management Italian is so far far
off from what you're doing but indian
food Thai food that kind of thing is
that growing at all in Greece not as the
fastest here or basic but it's not
because it's not accepted it's not if
you are not willing to try it but
there's something and I think it goes
back to this fellow Timo mean you're
you're proud of what you have you you're
willing to try something different but
it you you sort of want to showcase what
you have and it you know it's good for
you you know you've carried it for
generations of those and angry so why
not embrace that even more so in terms
of gender is it equal between you know
men doing the cooking and women doing
the cooking or is it per don
leave one or the other predominantly
women then we'll do the cooking probably
Easter and outdoors grilling the
grilling so it's mostly spa and it goes
like I said generation after generation
you have your grandmother's recipe who
got it from her grandmother and that and
there is something to be said about that
tradition that keeps it going on right I
know you're going to be doing a
conference here at the macmillan coming
up shortly so what do you would it first
talk about the conference and what are
you expecting to find though the we
decided to do to two panels on this on
this conference to tie nutrition public
health and feel ultimo first one
actually happened late us fall where we
had people from the agriculture
university of athens and somebody who's
in the industry olive oil industry who's
used this ideal people want to go back
into the agricultural world and started
small groups to throw instill in them
the idea that it is okay to be a farmer
we've been doing this for many many
years and it's good for everybody and
then sort of started some programs so
that was a one aspect to show that how
is that working the second one is tying
more the idea of this financial crisis
how do people come around and bond with
food and producing food and how does
that help for one address the financial
aspect of things you know we know things
are getting more expensive if you
sources from other places that we were
expensive why don't we produce ourselves
sources locally and at the same time
bring back that that power of the other
you know I'm doing something good I'm
proud of what I'm doing and and sort of
change that attitude that agriculture is
not for us anymore well that is
interesting because i'm thinking have
things evolve to a point where you know
where farmers aren't look our lower on
the socio-economic level and you know
Greeks aspire to be more than that so
now there's kind of a I don't want to
say a public relations campaign but more
of a way to show how it is you know more
highly thought of is there that kind of
thing that's changing definitely that's
changing the last few years I've seen
it's no longer bad thing to be a farmer
because farmers are very knowledgeable
what they do with some help they can go
to a level where they never thought they
would be before and now with
globalization again the example of olive
oil producers now before it was you're
selling your olive oil to somebody who
come to buy the box now you're proud of
your own olive oil you're going to be
willing to participate in a cup or
something that will help you either sell
it within the country or exported so now
there's a different way of looking at
I'm a farmer oil producer on the wine
producer and you know just like wally
world wines have seen a lot of success i
agree in the u.s. from greece from small
wine producers who thought 10 years ago
you told them i'm going to be selling
your wine in the US and they looked at
your life who would buy my wine so there
was that proud tried to produce
something but the same time feeling a
little bit who'd buy my products and now
that's changing and I think part of it
is a necessity to understand that we
have to go forward with this idea and
part of it is yeah it's good why not so
you're exporting a lot more than you had
previously doing in terms of wine and
olive oil anything else producing well a
lot of like I said if you look at the
Greek cuisine and the prenda the the
component ingredients they're very local
and people now moving into identifying
particular products is unique to the
precise about part for example the
island of Santorini there's a split pea
a yellow split pea that they've actually
did chemical analysis to show that it's
unique to that island so now they're
packaged producing a package and
exporting it with that unique identity
genetic identity that says this
particular legume is only grown on this
island in that general irma Syria them
and now it's done profits can be done
with cheeses with
all other products or bad product so it
gives you a lot of hope how things are
moving at right yeah it is interesting
because chefs are always will go for
that next shot product to use so that's
very exciting and it makes me want to
visit good this is good yes I should
thank you so much for being here with us
all day very interesting thank you for
having me okay for more information
about professor karoke DS and his
research please visit our website at
macmillan reports led you be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at you
[Music]
you